coming up on 5 56 on your friday shaping
the future beyond the 95 and the
northern 215 beltway ready let's go
centennial
bowling
now if this sounds familiar it should we
mentioned it a couple of times i just
don't want you to miss out on the
opportunity to chime in on exactly how
and where i 11 will traverse not only
the las vegas metropolitan area from
henderson but also the multiple possible
paths to northern nevada so they've
already had two public meetings there
are three more to go there's one next
tuesday at the lifeguard arena in
henderson a week from next tuesday at
the regional transportation commission
offices near the county government
center they wrap up thursday the 16th at
the windmill library in the south valley
so there are two basic paths one being
the 95 515 all the way up through the
centennial bowl the other being the 215
beltway on the south side goes up to a
couple of different options to connect
to the 95 but whether you come to an
in-person meeting or not i want all you
junior traffic buddies to check out the
virtual meeting at
i11nv.com there's a ton of stuff there
about the project we've got the links in
the online version of this as well as
all of our centennial bowling stories
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com